>> Hi, I'm an old astronaut/Mir cosmonaut.
I spent about five months off the planet and
now I'm -- here in Davos
on the planet.
I've been over this place a couple thousand
times so it's nice to be
down on the earth now and actually putting
my footprint here.
You know, my big love and life now is the
world's water and fresh
resources.
I was out in space looking down on the planet
and you see the great
rivers of the world, you know, the Tigris,
Euphrates, the Nile, the
Ganges, the Yangtze, you know, defining civilizations.
Wanna go to Mars someday.
When we go to Mars what's the first thing
we're looking at?
Where are we gonna get the water if we wanna
survive on Mars?
Spent five months up, closed ecosystem, we
had to make our air; we
actually took our urine, converted it into
water and then we would use
that as drinking water; we also used the sweat,
we condensed it, we'd
use that water, put the hydrogen off and we'd
breathe the oxygen from
that H2O.
So in a closed ecosystem for five months,
failing life support systems
you figure out very quickly that, uh, water's
essential, uh, in that
closed ecosystem you mess up, you get the
result very quickly.
Here on earth, you know, looking from space
at the earth, same thing.
Closed ecosystem. We mess up our resources
down here, especially our
water -- fresh water supplies -- uh, you know,
we're gonna pay the
consequences.
Unfortunately on earth it kinda buffers things
out.
You got thousands of millions of people down
here so you don't get it.
Closed ecosystem, three people, you contaminate
the water source and
you find out the next day that you're in trouble.
So I guess my plea from here in Davos World
Economic Forum that we
need to tap our fresh water resources around
the world and in the
developing world get some fresh drinking water
for all the children,
for the families that need it.
Uh, in the developed world, taking care of
the resources, the beauty
of our planet and, uh, keeping the circle
of blue as it looks like
from space clean, pure, and blue for future
generations.
Astronaut Jerry Lineger signing out.
Thanks.